hello my friend hello hello there's no
entry okay okay but we have we have a
safe conduct I'm gonna take it out and
I'm gonna open it so you can you can
read it okay okay what's your name
you don't care okay football football
stickers okay no problem
it's okay do you like football I love it
but you know what here almost nobody
understand football these stickers come
from Spain you know where Spain is look
I'm going to show you one one sticker
okay just one look
more Liga hey you know he illegally
peninsula to school earlier today to be
a party for come to caftan again he
lives lost enemy Island isn't didn't die
here for your there am I in our leader
so mindfulness is soda husk there mrs.
Fiona he's ever seen big our boy horses
some holes are became part of better
world of ski
would you mind telling me how long you
have believed yourself to be a god I may
ask you the same question I do not
believe myself to be a God you believe
yourself to be a psychiatrist yes since
I began practicing my profession I have
been a God ever since I began practicing
my profession I see now what are your
profession involve ongoing maintenance
chiefly maintenance of what
and the universe
so you created the universe exactly nine
days ago evidence suggests that the
universe is somewhat older than nine
days I know I created the events - well
first of all Wow and congratulations
truly original work each and every one
of you I would like to jump in here why
you chose the short film for your story
and did that decision impose any
specific requirements or constraints on
your story that you wanted to tell and
someone recommended me a book and within
the book there is a short section and
the only restrictions we had Lee's had
to get permission off the rights holders
of the novel it's authorized to take the
small section of the novel journeys were
short film those are the only
difficulties were really hard and I was
interested in the short session because
it deals with same themes of mental
illness and religion I don't see much
difference that's a yes yes religion
slightly more voluntary for me yes doing
short is also a way to practice I would
love to do a feature someday but I've
done free shorts this is my third short
film but but I guess also if you decide
to do a short you should really write a
story or do a story that fits the format
a lot of people doing short sometimes I
feel maybe they really wanted to do a
feature I've I think the short format
has this advantage that you really have
to kind of think really hard on what's
up if you want to talk about and how you
want to deal with it because you you
only have you know a certain amount of
minutes so you really have to kind of
get into the core of the theme and the
story and in that way I think sort films
is a fantastic format to work with
it is it's an extraordinary format and
so let's keep with this particular
question if we could mentally mean toget
in a format or atop elastic automate
remained a poor K Amica so some
terminator supuesto nosotros vamos
contrast astoria teníamos poco dinero
area most bro
to self analogy CMOS petrol minutos
people sol kilometer ahead talking about
the requirements for this sure like i
don't know what to tell you honestly we
had a low budget and then we wanted to
tell this story so we wanted to we had
to reduce everything into 24 minutes in
order to make the short it was the
budget it was one of the reasons the
budget yeah actually our short film
started from a script competition where
they were looking for for short comedy
scripts and after reading their
announcement I immediately knew that I
have I have an idea for this because
yeah I already had an idea about this
morning this chaotic morning and and I
really tried to write about it so I knew
that it's going to be a short story it's
like it's a it's one morning story so so
it was it was easy to start with but it
took a while to find a right and go to
to the story but after
behaving badly myself with my family so
I knew that okay this is it because I
started to laugh at myself so so but it
was it was quite obvious that this is a
short story and does should feel okay
great what she said yep well alright yes
as a wife and a mother the question does
you know I don't want to assume how
autobiographical the elements in the
film were perhaps you could elaborate
have you it wasn't an actual wedding was
there how much from from your life was
at all fiction or just every day of your
life is taking care of everything so
well at the same time I think that every
second of this film is is fictional
totally fictional okay
might open Kim you've previously
received an Oscar and three additional
nominations for your shorts have these
awards and the others you have received
made it easier did they in fact make it
easier for you to make this short film I
don't think so I think is always a
challenge and we've done a lot of short
yes and we had a good run here at the
Academy so feels like a good home but we
do it you know to support new talent and
actually to see and so if we have if
there's some new town that we can grow
with so that's what we take it in in the
Danish film industry a little like the
finish I think we have a public support
schemes and is you know you just can't
come in from the street and make a
feature film you have to show and prove
everybody that you can you know direct
and you can put four images together and
all these kind of things before you
actually get support I mean it's the
same all over the world but
and that's what we use it for we use it
to to find talent and grow with that and
and tell good stories and I think along
the lines what and I was just saying is
I think I love the short format I mean
we do a lot of features as well in our
company but I love the short format
because it doesn't have the pressure of
any industry or that it has to do a box
office success or anything like that you
can actually free and just do it ever
you want to do and I think is very true
you have to be true to the format is is
it 10 minutes 15 25 whatever but be true
to it so you don't try to make something
too long or too big or anything for that
just to prove yourself you just have to
be true to the story yeah it is easy to
assume in the short form you have
complete freedom and creative control
and answering only to your muse would
the others agree with that I think in
our situation we were extremely
fortunate to have purely private backing
so we didn't win when under pull to any
film funding body or a body or anything
like that so it really just opened
things up we were very fortunate to have
invested it just let us get on with it
100% so it really gives a purity to the
form that we that we work with the way
we approached it it was so easy solely
and at the whim of mark and and I and I
think we did an okay job
well given the Oscar nomination that's
probably true
how are you then with the restraints
from the feature film world asking much
more of you and offering a painful
amount of insight and and the idea of
losing control by moving on to a feature
you had mentioned that you were looking
forward to doing features you had
mentioned that you loved to thrive in
this world of short film and find the
talent and watch them grow but I think I
mean if you in the future world is it's
not that you're giving up you just
that's just so many more elements and
needs to fit together and order for it
to you know to succeed I mean if you go
in there you have your script you have
your financing you need the distributor
you have demand for what audience you're
hitting what target when is it gonna
premiering what festivals are you going
for me it's just putting on all these
more layers in order for it to get
greenlit in a way yeah I mean in helium
we produced it ourselves because we
didn't get backing I mean we got some
script support but then they went on to
basically say that they didn't think we
could succeed and make a movie out of it
so they stopped us for doing it but we
went on to do it ourselves and but just
going on there was that next the next
step to move up to the feature film you
just so many more layers to put on and
it just is it's just something more to
take care of right well they're all such
extraordinary accomplishments quite
frankly and and I don't mean to be glib
about well you've got the validation of
the Academy Award nomination quite the
opposite the empowerment as I said
before the break that forevermore
it's Academy Award and then either
nominated or winner and then your name
for the rest of your lives this is for
some of you a beginning of greater
opportunities and
I happen to know for a fact for one of
you not so much
I'm not at liberty to say which it pains
me not to share with you now
can I just add some please this question
I'm just thinking that it's true what
what they said about making a feature
film and having more pressure with that
but I had I don't have experience on
making a feature film yet or not a
fiction feature film but um so yeah it's
probably true that there will be more
pressure but I hope that once I do make
a fiction feature that that I will still
eventually gain the freedom there will
be just more pressure on me from from
from these different instances but it's
it's kind of like a challenge for me yes
I hope that I can overcome those
challenges you know and and the and the
outcome will be again the the freedom of
short film but it's just it will just be
more challenging yeah I mean the idea is
that this will afford you opportunities
to do more work that everyone who sees
these films is going to say I want to
work with these people I want to give
them opportunities so then the question
is would you like your next project to
be long-form feature or would you like
to continue to thrive as you have
gloriously in short form I think
definitely 94 features yeah ready for
feature yeah I think I'll say it by the
pressures of feature filmmaking I just
think to me personally I just choose a
story that only I could tell yeah
and so it removes all about pressure
then if I sell an idea to people but
they they can't see the difference
between me and the story that they can't
see the film without me then the
pressure is off in some way and then
I'll just hide behind Baldwin
well it's a design that's me it's an
exciting sort of pressure that's why
maybe you got into this absolutely so
that someone might one day put pressure
on you yeah but they know that's
ultimately your goal absolutely as a
director keeps it you know there are so
many layers to doing a feature you have
to you know what is your target group
and all these things you have to think
about but as a director and the creative
force on a film I mean I think if you
find the right story if it's a short
film or feature story it doesn't really
matter I mean the pressure I think you
kind of just let go because you'll never
be able to create anything with that
pressure hanging on your shoulders or
trying to figure out what the audience
want so I think going into the feature
would be the same process it's a
creative process and you just have to be
true to whatever story you're doing and
I don't I mean I haven't done it so far
maybe I will feel the pressure when I
when I get on the set hopefully I'll get
other features here but I think you will
forget about all these things when
you're there and I think the process
will be the same you know doing a short
doing a feature whatever it's a creative
thing and I think when you stand on
drive you that pressure to do to do
great work yeah I hope so yeah CMMI
caste system atrophy in my cases it's my
six short movie espero que los dientes
yeah and I hope that my next things a
feature movie last possibility is a
preview Oscar regarding the projection
that this Oscar can give you know me now
I am the fifth director for my country
that has been nominated and the others
all have done careers in feature movies
seek a spirit and a lemming much for
taking the opportunity academia so I I
hope I'm as lucky as they are on my next
opportunities to do a feature movie
that's real pressure
yeah yeah you you can't mess this up now
you've made a wonderful example of your
country mostly assuming you want to go
back there that may not be the case he
said I enjoy working with pressure that
is the correct answer you all do clearly
yeah there was great pressure to do what
you've done here it doesn't matter the
length of the film there's somebody
waiting for greatness and you have to
deliver and the Academy Award nomination
has more than suggested you've delivered
beyond expectation and I think we owe
them all a great congratulations as a
group